We Begin this morning with hurricane
Ian's destructive path across Florida
and now South Carolina just two days
after Ian demolished parts of Southwest
and Central Florida the revived
hurricane took aim at South Carolina the
storm was killed at least 22 people but
that number is expected to rise nearly 2
million people in several states are
without electricity First Responders
have already rescued thousands of people
Ian weakened to a tropical storm as a
track Inland it's about 30 miles south
of Greensboro North Carolina and moving
North now on Friday Ian slammed into
South Carolina as a powerful category
one hurricane the storm flooded
neighborhoods and damaged cheers Mark
Strassman is in Myrtle Beach South
Carolina with the latest Mark of morning
uh good morning Jeff Ian's threat
remains real here and to give you a
sense of its power look at that beach
Shrimp Boat behind me its crew was
rescued and then the storm pushed it two
miles on Shore landfall actually
happened about 40 miles south of here in
Georgetown South Carolina in a part of
the state known as the low country and
in parts of that region flood waters
overwhelmed areas that sit at or below
sea level the storm was uh created a
storm surge of up to seven feet and
through the early morning hours another
blast of storm surge remains a worry at
one point two hundred thousand people
lost power the latest number 65 000. in
Pawleys Island police describe the
flooding as catastrophic it's Pier
collapsed and at last sighting was
floating South in the Atlantic but
Statewide Ian here was mostly a wind
event Winds of update 85 miles per hour
up and down the South Carolina coast
reports of flooding became the dominant
worry in South Carolina evacuation
orders were never issued some people
trapped by suddenly Rising Waters needed
rescuing from Homes apartments and cars
in any disaster loss is personal if it's
your house that got flooded it hurts but
in this case if you compare what
happened in scale to Florida you
understand why people here generally
believe Ian gave them a break
Dana